[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti lieto di essere qui e
di aprire anche l'onore se il primo
bisogna fare economia di tempo felice di
essere qui perché sono acqua nelle
marche ci sto veramente bene faccio
anche il direttore artistico del premio
arturo ghergo a montefano ho curato
questa magnifica mostra di robert capa
dalla mole che forse avete già visitato
e che chiude tra pochi giorni e tornerò
di nuovo ad ancona il primo giugno per
fare una conferenza che si intitola
buonanotte mister capa come avrete
capito che apre il mio autore preferito
e quindi sono davvero contento di aver
fatto questa mostra questa operazione
alcune cose sono già state dette appunto
gli occhi del mondo io ho scelto dieci
immagini e che secondo me hanno cambiato
il mondo perché questa vicenda del
diciamo delle delle fotografie fise
fotografare significa prendersi cura di
tutti noi e questa citazione era
saltiamo nell'economia del tempo perché
già è già stato detto perché hans questo
lo dicesse la adams e non io tu non fai
solo una fotografia con la macchina
fotografica tu metti nella fotografia
tutte le immagini che hai visto i libri
che ha letto la musica e che hai
ascoltato e le persone che hai amato
io l'ho trovata una citazione
meravigliosa perché è vero perché è così
perché i fotografi forse è arrivato il
momento di smettere di considerare i
fotografi come dei documentaristi o i
fotografi sono degli interpreti sono
fanno delle trasfigurazioni della della
realtà
e poi c'è questa cosa che ha detto a
diane arbus che io penso sia
incredibilmente vera perché dice credo
davvero che esistano cose che nessuno
riesce a vedere prima che vengano
fotografate perché la realtà una volta
che è fotografata per l'appunto cambia
completamente e diventano delle delle
fotografie e adesso poi vediamo delle
immagini questa è l'ultima
e dice la fotografia non può mentire
come lo strumento non può mentire ma i
bugiardi possono scattare fotografie e
quindi bisogna imparare
abitare delle immagini o quantomeno a
rendersene conto
questa è la prima fotografia che questo
signore daguerre che l'inventore
quest'anno si celebrano i 180 anni della
fotografia viene presentata nel 1839
parigi e da guerre per presentare questa
straordinaria invenzione da arago va con
questa fotografia e questa fotografia è
molto curiosa perché vedete con il laser
sto puntando questi due signori perché
la fotografia quando nasce non può
assolutamente riprendere soggetti
dinamici può riprendere soltanto
soggetti statici perché aveva bisogno di
tempi di posa lunghissimi si presume che
per fare questa fotografia da guerra
abbia esposto alla pellicola pensate non
avevano neanche inventato l'otturatore
si toglieva e si metteva il copri
obiettivo e si lasciava che la luce si
depositasse sulla pellicola
in questo caso per 20 minuti e quindi
noi ci chiediamo ma come fanno ad
esserci il lustrascarpe e il suo cliente
in una situazione del genere non è
possibile perché nessuno può rimanere
fermo per 20 minuti
quindi gli storici dicono che daguerre
pur di farci vedere il mondo attenzione
questa è il segreto di questa immagine
perché uno vuole raccontare il mondo
perché lo vuole migliorare perché vuole
farlo proprio perché vuole metterci un
pezzetto delle sue idee dei suoi
sentimenti per farla breve daguerre ha
chiesto al bus tra scarpe al suo cliente
di stare fermi 20 minuti e di posare per
lui quindi si può dire se siete
d'accordo che la prima fotografia quella
che annuncia l'invenzione è una menzogna
la fotografia nasce con il virus della
menzogna
non è vero che bisogna aspettare
photoshop per mentire o per taroccare le
fotografie le fotografie si modificano
ancora prima che la fotografia venisse
inventata e tu le puoi modificare
assolutamente perché vuoi che il mondo
stia tuo nel momento dello scatto no
perché l'abbiamo detto la fotografia non
può mentire mai bugiardi che è
un'esagerazione e possono fotografare
quindi questa immagine per me
assolutamente significativa perché ci
consente di fare un ragionamento molto
più lineare quest'altra è un'immagine
che mi ha sempre molto colpito perché è
diventato un'icona siamo nel 1945 e c'è
il day fa questa fotografia poi la
portano per essere pubblicata
ma si rendono conto che in russia
avevano trafugato un orologio no e
quindi è praticamente devono rimettere
in scena tutta la fotografia
noi abbiamo sempre guardato questa
fotografia come la conquista del
reichstag
e invece è una fotografia che viene
ricostruita che viene rimessa in scena
nella storia della fotografia è piena di
esempi e piena di storie e di situazioni
che hanno a che fare con la
ricostruzione con diciamo con la
menzogna fa proprio vedete il
particolare però il tutto cambia ne
parlavo prima con l'amico italo qualcomm
aldridge perché fino a quando la
fotografia non conquista
tecnicamente il movimento è incompleta e
siccome voi sapete bene che le cose
esistono solo se vengono raccontate se
una cosa non viene raccontata non esiste
e questo mondo per come dire per
migliorarlo per farlo nostro
per dobbiamo imparare a raccontarlo e io
sono grato ai fotografi che ancora
nonostante la grande crisi delle
dell'immagine dell'editoria lo fanno
pensate che questo signore ha messo in
linea 24 macchine fotografiche e le ha
fatte scattare a distanza di pochissimo
uno dall'altra perché voleva capire
davvero come com'era la corsa dei
cavalli perché veniva rappresentata nei
quadri in un modo veramente bizzarro
sembrava che il cavallo volasse no a un
certo punto però lui è come dire poi
queste grazie a questa invenzione si
riescono a fare degli studi
sull'anatomia e la conquista del
movimento cambia completamente il
linguaggio della fotografia
e naturalmente cambia anche la
narrazione del mondo però la fotografia
s'è messa nelle mani di persone
intelligenti come dire ci aiutano
davvero a capire come migliorare ancora
e come prenderci cura del mondo questo
signore rossa geologo si chiama lewis
hine affatto 80.000 km nel 1916 è
riuscito grazie alle sue fotografie a
mettere fine a questo sfruttamento del
lavoro minorile che nel 1908 quando lui
comincia questo lavoro negli stati uniti
era cosa comune e grazie ad un dossier
di fotografie che lewis hine produce in
tutti questi anni appunto facendo più di
80.000 km negli stati uniti le mette sul
tavolo dei legislatori e queste
finalmente si rendono conto dello
scandalo e mettono fine a questa roba
che non aveva veramente alcun senso
la vecchia ve lo avevo annunciato prima
questa è la foto dello sbarco di
normandia che ha visto il film salvate
il soldato ryan sicuramente sa che
spielberg si è ispirato a queste
fotografie per girare questo film allora
e k si è preso cura del mondo voleva
fare bene le cose
ma c'è una storia dietro queste
fotografie che molti non sanno perché
come vedete io non è che ho scelto una
fotografia a bassa risoluzione sono
veramente così se voi andate a vederle
pubblicate sui libri sono sgranate e
sono mosse beh insomma qui siamo a
londra e john morris che il
caporedattore di life manda capa a fare
lo sbarco di normandia lo sbarco di
normandia lo stavano aspettando tutti
perché si sapeva che quello come dire
sarebbe stata la vicenda che avrebbe
cambiato le sorti del mondo quindi
qualcuno la doveva raccontare e bob come
tutti gli amici lo chiamavano va poi
manda una staffetta con 12 rulli e
quando john morris che nella sede
periferica di londra vede arrivare
comincia subito una trattativa con la
sede centrale di new york perché dice
bob ha fatto le foto
faremo un numero speciale voglio 20
nella copertina quelli dicono no noi la
copertina non te la diamo perché non
sappiamo così l'operatore diamo qui
insomma una trattativa pazzesca
e intanto dai rulli da sviluppare e
questo diciamo neve ne sviluppa i primi
due i primi tre poi torna su da john
morris e gli dice sono fantastici bob ha
fatto un lavoro incredibile ora quello
richiama life e dice voglio 30 pagine
voglio la doppia copertina insomma una
trattativa pazzesca poi chiama tutta la
redazione perché dice dobbiamo brindare
perché life farà il massimo della delle
delle tirature
beh insomma poi alla fine cosa succede
che il tecnico di laboratorio preso
dall'entusiasmo dello sviluppo fa una
stupidata tecnica e dei dodici rullini
che bob aveva scattato rimangono 11
fotografie e queste undici sono tutte
rovinato e perché si è sciolta
l'emulsione e quindi quando il
giornalista mette di queste perché poi a
quel punto john morris abbassare la
testa non gli danno la copertina gli
danno delle pagine ecco qua che le
vedete è il giornalista dice slight in
un autofocus leggermente fuori fuoco e
quando pensate
robert capa scrive la sua autobiografia
la intitola leggermente fuori fuoco e
finalmente racconta questa vicenda e
dice le mie foto erano a fuoco io avevo
una paura del diavolo perché sono un
uomo come voi e sarei stato stupido non
avere paura e anzi mi proteggeva ma
quelle foto sono così e qui racconta la
storia dell'incidente tecnico che ha
rovinato le foto per cui pensate quanto
importante queste dodici foto l'unica
testimonianza che rimasta di quella
giornata clamorosa appunto che il d day
sono di robert capa è la stessa vicenda
riguarda e questo fotografo nick che nel
72 scatta questa fotografia un certo
punto non la vuole pubblicare perché
dice ma io non voglio pubblicare la foto
di una bambina nuda
dopo di che racconta la storia e qui
come dire il napalm viene buttato da un
elicottero dall'alto brucia i vestiti di
questa bambina che disperata corre e
alla fine luis capisce che questa
immagine contiene perché poi
lei è lì che piace così ma guardate quel
bambino in primissimo piano che è
diventato paradossalmente meno famoso
perché i suoi vestiti non sono bruciati
sapete che lei l'hanno ritrovata anche
recentemente sono la storia è tutta
bizzarra beh insomma con grazie a questa
fotografia che viene pubblicata in tutto
il mondo si inizia la battaglia civile
per dire basta la guerra in vietnam cioè
grazie a una fotografia grazie al potere
della comunicazione grazie all'impegno
di questo fotografo si può né come dire
iniziare una ecco qua c'è tutta la
storia
e poi un'altra storia completamente
diversa quella di ansel adams che passa
per un fotografo di paesaggio in realtà
era un sociologo incredibile e pensate
che i grandi parchi americani esistono
perché è esistito l'ansel adams perché
lui amava così tanto poi posti andava
così tanto quei luoghi ea ed è riuscito
a mettere a fuoco una un linguaggio così
specifico riguardo al paesaggio per cui
anche lui in questo caso grazie ad un
dossier di fotografie dà vita ai papà ai
grandi parchi americani gordon parks è
un genio intanto è il primo fotografo di
colore ad entrare nello staff di life e
quando fa questa fotografia che perché
praticamente lui racconta grazie a
questa fotografia tutta la vicenda che
ha a che fare con il con il razzismo con
il separatismo prende vita proprio
grazie a questa a questa fotografia che
si rifà come potete vedere ad un quadro
famosissimo un po diciamo che che
riassume in modo anche piuttosto ironico
e preciso il dominio della supremazia
del dei bianchi e ma addirittura degli
uomini verso verso le donne quello qua
che che fa appunto il primo è lui
documentò tutti gli aspetti e dei gay
nei ghetti le manifestazioni per i
diritti civili e quindi anche tutti i
leader che hanno lavorato su quello ho
voluto mettere anche una fotografa
italiana io ho una sua mostra
a venezia la casa dei tre oci letizia
battaglia ecco qua vi voglio dire una
cosa semplicissima ognuno di noi
architetti e designer prenditori e
fotografi scrittori abbiamo una modalità
di mettere in scena la nostra dimensione
la nostra vita eco letizia battaglia è
riuscita perché vuole così bene al mondo
vuole migliorarlo vuole farlo proprio e
riuscita a dare un volto alla mafia
perché non dimentichiamoci che c'è stato
anche chi ha detto che la mafia non
esiste
lei ha lavorato tutta la vita per
restituire il dramma della mafia e tutti
i giorni alla stregua di wiki stava lì a
palermo con una squadra di fotografi che
aveva costruito lei e tutti i giorni
andava a fotografare come dice lei
i morti ammazzati della mafia ma come
dire senza pudore con grande coraggio
perché era necessario restituire questo
e questo volto
diane arbus l'abbiamo detto prima e qua
quando diceva una buona fotografia non
può migliorare il mondo ma una cattiva
sicuramente lo peggiora quindi non
facciamo brutte fotografie a me mi ha
sempre colpito questo bambino quando
vedete sembra in preda ad una crisi di
nervi è tutto teso e tutto tirato e poi
sono andato a indagare su questa vicenda
al di confesso che il mio sogno che
potrebbe veramente contribuire a
migliorare il mondo è quello di fare una
mostra di diane arbus ma questo lo
racconto perché siamo in un tel
non ci sono ancora riuscito ma ci sto
lavorando
e poi sono andato a vedere in un libro
molto raro che si chiama revelations
tutta i contact cioè i provini a
contatto e la riuscita a vedere come
questo bambino è dolce come questo
bambino è uguale a tutti gli altri
bambini che giocano dei tagli ai parchi
ma lei sceglie di pubblicare questa
fotografia
quindi questo per me diventa importante
perché ci fa capire come il fotografo
non è un registratore
il fotografo vuole raccontarci il
proprio punto di vista e se ne assume il
coraggio se ne assume la responsabilità
e io come dire invito tutti a fare
questo perché dobbiamo imparare a
prendere posizione
dobbiamo imparare ad essere critici
dobbiamo imparare a dire la nostra in un
momento in cui sembra che questo non
accada più questa è un'altra storia
pazzesca un'altra foto incredibile devo
andare velocissimo pensate che questo
fotografo eddie adams è morto con il
senso di colpa di aver generato la morte
di questa spia vietcong perché perché
lui era in giro con due macchine
fotografiche e questo capitano che lo
vede gli dice ma cosa stai facendo voi
americani siete come i cowboy quelle
macchine sono come due colt e dice ma
veramente io sto qua a raccontare una
storia e dice se vuoi una storia te la
faccio vedere io ma de di essere veloce
uno due tre bombe e star a quello è il
dramma vero è che lui riesce a fare una
foto
questa è la cosa pazzesca va bene questa
pechino però posso andare avanti perché
tanto come dire la conosciamo perché
siamo quasi in chiusura e vorrei
chiudere con salgado perché è come dire
sebastiao salgado con il quale ho avuto
il piacere di lavorare abbiamo prodotto
anche insieme a contrasto tutta la
vicenda di genesi grazie alla fotografia
grazie a questo suo desiderio di fare le
cose di farle bene
genesi questa grande mostra che che
credo che sia stata anche qua e lui ci
ha messo otto anni per produrla perché è
come dire arriva dal brasile
non so se sapete la storia suo papà
aveva un range in brasile e tutta la sua
zona è stata praticamente desertificata
e quindi lui come dire grazie alla sua
capacità di fare bene e di fare delle
buone fotografie è riuscito ricomprarsi
la terra del padre ea ripiantumato
ripiantumato centinaia di migliaia di
alberi e sono tornati gli animali sono
tornate è tornata alla vita quella zona
e il corriere della sera ne dà una
notizia veramente recentemente quindi
proprio questo c'è i fotografi come dire
alla stregua di chiunque è in grado di
compiere delle azioni azioni conoscitive
questo è un autore preciso pieno di
consapevolezza
sappiamo che fotografare significa
mettere in scena
avere amore per quello che si fa e
poterlo migliorare io vi ringrazio tutti
grazie mille
grazie